like almost everything in our lives our
sleep and dreams are being affected by
the coronavirus in a Harvard survey more
than 2,000 people described 5,000 kovat
related dreams in the past month
they include nightmares about getting
the virus and anxiety dreams about
forgetting to wear masks outside dr.
Carol Ashe is a sleep specialist and
chief medical officer at RWJ Barnabas
health in Rahway New Jersey good morning
dr. Ashe I know so many people who've
been telling me they've had strange
dreams recently including myself I've
had a couple of really surreal ones the
kind where you wake up and you go what
was that so what is going on in our
heads well Anthony dreams are a
physiologic signal and they're normal we
have them all the time sometimes we
don't know we are having them but it's
your body and your brain processing the
events and experiences experiences of
the day it's for emotional processing
and it helps us prepare for future
events
so is it basically healthy to have these
dreams as disturbing as some of them may
be well they they are healthy and you
can have dreams along a spectrum when
you have these dreams that night again
for that emotional processing it helps
to regulate your emotions during the day
it down regulates those those anxious
feelings and studies have shown that
when you don't sleep well at night your
anxiety is increased by 30% so good
sleep and dreams they're a normal
healthy process and unfortunately with
all the things we're dealing with this
with this coronavirus we're all going
through collective trauma so we're
seeing more and more of these vivid
dreams nightmares it's not uncommon to
have sleep disruption and nightmares
during trauma but what also is happening
Anthony is some of us because we're not
working our schedules are disrupted and
we're sleeping in we're actually getting
more sleep and you have more dreams
right before you awaken in the morning
so most of us are actually experiencing
dreams for the first time
so we're finding our dreams are more
vivid because we just haven't had the
opportunity to really get good quality
sleep what kinds of dreams are you
hearing about from your patients well
there's a whole spectrum Anthony we have
people that are talking about virtual
dreams where they're literally dreaming
about the virus all the way to metaphors
people feeling like they're there
they're running away or they're there
they're dreaming about people touching
them swarms of bugs and unfortunately
obviously we have those health care
providers on the front lines that are
experiencing real trauma you know it's
it's hard to be dealing with this
coronavirus and doing what we do and
some some of those folks are
experiencing nightmares and having some
real difficulties we're also in this
period of social isolation that most of
us have not experienced if that
affecting how we sleep well this is
really an interesting thing obviously so
the the social distancing it is
critically important we all need to
stick to that and we're seeing wonderful
outcomes because of it social isolation
it is a perceived sense of loss for many
of us you know the daily routines are
interactions with folks it defines a
sense of self so there's this perceived
loss of sense of self it's increasing
anxiety and an anxiety and stress will
disrupt your sleep at night and here's
the interesting part Anthony when you
disrupt your sleep at night it activates
the part of the brain for protection so
you have a greater sense that your space
is being violated so you you really
don't even want to be around people so
it magnifies that sense of isolation and
loss so it's not as bad as we think
we're gonna get through this stick to
the social distancing and we really can
cope it's the way the brain works that's
giving that us that perceived additional
sense of loss and isolation
alright dr. Carol ash thank you so much
for being with us this morning